these last two guys are the two worst
people that have ever been [__]
president in my life they neither one of
them are presidential material it's like
a [__] joke all right so we've both
elected a [__] jerk off all I want is
somebody sane in this next one like
Biden has to just put him in a [__]
home
that guy should be sitting on a porch
somewhere
yeah he can't even finish his speech to
it he clearly put sunglasses on him so
when he starts freaking out where he
doesn't know where he is that'll make
the stock market plunge he clearly knows
you can't have the president given a
basic speech about [__] whatever and
all of a sudden like he does get a scary
look in his eye when he goes up on his
lines he's your driver from LAX there is
are you looking at your phone are you
[__] looking at him the whole way
to make sure he doesn't take it down to
San Diego the good news is I don't think
you can press the gas pedal very hard